you got the wrong movie asshole
wanna fight
only God forgives is directed by Nicolas
Winding refa and stars Ryan Gosling
Kristin Scott Thomas and an extremely
talented actor whose name I cannot
pronounce I apologize this is a
interesting movie to describe the plot
of this movies rather difficult to
really sum up quickly essentially you
have a man whose brother is killed and
it's a very complicated situation you're
not exactly sure who's on the right side
who's on the wrong side what exactly do
you do in this situation and it starts a
revenge path that leaves Julianne played
by Ryan Gosling on a strange
metaphorical dreamlike journey through
some very violent occurrences I think
that's my best way that I can describe
this movie actually now you guys may
know this was actually my most
anticipated movie of 2013 I loved Drive
I have seen only a handful of films
since Drive that I actually think are
better than Drive I really loved that
movie and I know a lot of people think
it's overrated and don't enjoy it and
that's perfectly fine now this film is
available on demand right now and in
theaters I personally downloaded it off
of the Vudu app on my PlayStation 3 and
I watched it at home and I got to tell
you when it downloaded to my ps3 I sat
there with a controller about to press
play and this is what was going through
my head only God forgives is downloaded
to my PlayStation 3 and I'm about to
watch it oh my god if you haven't seen
troll to see it a lot of people were
like stuckman is gonna like this movie
no matter what he's gonna think
everything about it's perfect and he's
not gonna have any flaws with it because
he's a dr fanboy only God forgives is
not a perfect movie it really isn't it
has a lot of flaws there are things
about the movie that didn't work and
there are things about the movie that
were very impressive visually especially
visually this movie looks incredible
give me a movie that looks this
beautiful over a green screen CGI fest
any day I'm telling you the
cinematography in this movie is
astoundingly beautiful the use of
lighting is just immaculate and that's
clearly a humongous talent of Nicolas
Winding referent he knows what to do
with the camera he can create a very
mesmerizing scene and there are lots of
them and only
forgives the movie opens and I was just
instantly like riveted by the first like
10-15 minutes of this movie I was just
glued to the screen because it was so
well made okay so the movie looks good
how does it sound beautiful the
soundtrack by Cliff Martinez is just
euphoric and really cool and got this
great bead going on in the background a
lot of the time and very deep and dark
as well and I just love the way this
movie looked and sound aesthetically
this movie is the best looking movie
I've seen so far this year without a
doubt substance that's where we run into
our problem the character isn't only God
forgives aren't really characters all of
them are sort of like metaphors for
various things the character of the cop
in the movie I kind of viewed him as a
metaphor for God because he is this
all-powerful guy who isn't really even a
cop because I I know they say he's a cop
but he doesn't do anything that cops do
he kills whenever he wants he tortures
he does things that cops just don't do
he lets people kill people all the time
he just he's not really a cop so if you
look at this movie from a
straightforward factual realistic sense
you're gonna hate it but there's a lot
of metaphors going on in this film there
are certain scenes in the movie that
could be dreamlike that might have
happened that are existential it's all
very different okay if you don't like
art movies or if you didn't like drive
you're going to hate this movie I mean
because this movie makes Drive look
mainstream seriously if people complain
that Ryan Gosling didn't talk enough in
Drive they're gonna watch only God
forgives and think that he's saying
stairway to heaven and drive I mean he
barely says anything in this movie he
has lines that propel the story along
but certainly none that propelled his
character along you don't really get to
know him as a character and that brings
you back to what I said earlier the
characters in this but we don't really
feel like characters or people they feel
like metaphors did I like it overall I
would say that I was very interested as
I watched this movie there were aspects
of this movie that I really liked I
can't say I loved the movie there were
things about it that really bugged me
that didn't make sense that I didn't
think had to be there I know Nicholas
winning roughen has said that he has a
fetish for violence and that is clearly
seen and an over-the-top torture scene
in this movie that just went too far now
I love Drive that's a pretty violent
movie but all the violence in that movie
I felt had meaning for me when I watched
only God forgives there were certain
violent scenes that felt like they were
violent just to be violent without any
meaning and that's the kind of violence
that I can't stand that's the kind of
violence that disturbs me and that's the
kind of stuff and only God forgives that
I did not like and it was really just
one scene and then one shot in the movie
that I felt were like not necessary okay
that doesn't have to go that far the
acting in the movie is really strong I
mean Gosling is good it's just he
doesn't really have anything to work
with he is essentially something to
propel the story along as I said he's
not really a character I don't really
view him as a character because he
really just feels like a metaphor for
certain things especially with the way
the film ended which is going to enrage
a lot of people and there were certain
aspects of it that definitely bothered
me where I just went really okay I guess
but then I started thinking about it and
I understood what he was trying to say
and for that reason I was able to come
to peace with the way the film ended I
just wished Nikolas winning roughen
would have made a slightly more
straightforward story I'm all for art
films I love art films I just wish that
this film had a more cohesive story and
characters that I could get more
invested in that being said there were
moments in this movie that were truly
masterful I mean masterful like Stanley
Kubrick great stuff going on here
moments that really had me on the edge
of my seat that I was just like wow I
can see people watching this 50 years
from now and thinking this is an
absolute masterpiece I mean this is just
beautiful and for that reason I can't
say this is a bad movie what I will say
as it is disappointing and I wanted it
to be better than it was I didn't expect
it to be like Drive I didn't go into
this movie expecting that I just wanted
a good movie it's just not quite what I
wanted it to be only God forgives is a
beautiful looking movie with a terrific
soundtrack some good performances it's
honestly a movie that I'd like to see
again to examine more for that reason
I'm going to give the film a b-minus I
do think that it is a film worth seeing
I do think it's a film that you should
examine if you're interested in
filmmaking if you're interested in the
art of film however mainstream audiences
will hate this movie they will hate it
they will hate it you understand me they
will hate it and I'm not going to be
surprised at all because most people
hate it drive to don't care but I got to
give major props to winning referent for
making such a beautiful movie for being
courageous about the stories he's trying
to tell
are going away from the whole studio
thing from not caring about what other
people say I do think however that
Nikolas winning reference should
definitely hold back on some of the more
violent aspects of this film that aren't
necessary if we're going to put violence
in a movie make it have meaning make it
have a meaning to the story I feel like
some of the aspects of this film did and
then some didn't and I also know that
there were a lot of things that he was
trying to tell throughout this movie
that I get because he said it publicly
in interviews like this is what I wanted
to do here this is what I wanted to do
with this but that's one thing if you
say that's what you're trying to do if
your film doesn't really explain that to
the viewer or at least make it clear
there are some problems there so I can't
say it's a perfect movie and there you
go guys if you thought I was going to
love the movie you were wrong I gotta be
honest with you guys all the time and
remember this I'm not just gonna love a
movie just because I was hyped for it
I'll be honest with you no matter what
thanks as always guys for watching if
you see the movie I'm very interested in
knowing what you think about it it's
definitely gonna divide viewers it even
divided me a little bit I still got to
think about a lot and I'll probably
watch it again in the next few days but
as always guys thanks for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
Oh